bonjour à tous alors nouvelle vidéo sur
lionel qu'ils héritent ski donc il ya à
nouveau les noirs et qui opposait un
joueur s'appelle shelton john williams
parti jouer à paris en 1844 il est donc
comme je vous disais je voulais montrer
une partie de plaisir skis ou où ça se
passe bien pour lui parce que ben voila
j'ai dit dans la vidéo précédente que
c'était il a été considéré comme le
numéro un mondial sur fait un peu les
calculs pendant un moment et voilà c'est
dommage qu'on se rappelle de lui comme
le perdant dans la partie de l'immortel
donc on a regardé juste avant et donc
nouvelle partie donc il est à nouveau
les noirs et nouveaux concurrents dont 2
4 5 et 4 manches ou c4
eh ben ils rejouent ça rentre fétiche
même bon cette partie était jouée avant
l'autre en fait un sept ans plus tôt et
donc son fameux couple et 5 alors fou
prend cavalli m6 et là les bleus ont
fait cas et c3 donc défendre pions et
développe le cavalier pas mal mais le
coup le meilleur et je veux par andersen
savait était cavalier f3 ici développant
le cavalier et gagner un temps sur la
dame h4 bon il a fait cas les c3 cette
fois-ci kaiji quatre bons basiques
menace m'attend fde éventuellement
calibre en h2 donc alliage 3 défend un
peu tous très bien et c'est ici s'il se
développe est alors ici ouais on voit un
peu les les comment dire ni mauvais côté
et quoi du jeu à l'époque et avec les
blancs il part directe à l'assaut il
fait qu'il y ait des cinq avant même
d'avoir pensé à se développer
ou des choses comme ça mais en fait il
fait la même chose avec les noirs c'est
à dire qu'il pourrait peut-être jouer un
coup comme fou des six qui développerait
le fou qui défense est bon pourquoi pas
mais ignorant la pareille vas-y cahier
des quatre bombes à 4 ans et sept rois
des 8 et prend 1,8
donc ça commence fort on a un âge où
eddy coup les clients elle a déjà donné
une tour mais bon il ya peu ses pièces
vers le roi quoi donc il y va f3 f3 donc
l'idée évidemment c'est peut-être de
dévier se plonger deux évidemment puis
on prend serait très mauvais parce qu'il
ya juste des amis proches trois échecs
et si revin damage quatre échecs suivi
de ta meuf de maths au prochain un plein
et s'il est blanc faisait dix ont ragé 1
on pourrait simplement je fous ces cinq
suivis de cavaliers eu 2 ou cavaliers
prend f3 mat
dans les deux cas il n'y a pas de
défense en fait bon bien sûr il n'a pas
fait j'ai pris un f3 m'étais juste pour
expliquer un peu le lit des noirs
quelque part et il a fait il a fait
simplement des trois donc bah pas mal
sapin race ou de jouer et de deux ont
créé la menace food g5 qui attaquent à
la fois le roi et la dame
donc il est vite il fait 6 et l'a à
nouveau un coût moyen je pense en fait
il fait pousser 4 bat juste oui il faut
attaquer il l'enlève quoi mais vu qu'il
a déjà une tour de plus en fait sert à
rien d'être tellement matérialiste on
pourrait simplement jouer un couple
comme comme x 4 et donc si les noirs
venez apprendre b5 dame prend un f3 et
ça va pas mal on a toujours une qualité
de plus on a la dame qui joue le foot le
foot à f4 qui est développée on fera
peut-être fou g3 chassant la dame ou
d'alger 3 proposant une finale enfin
plein d'options possibles et et voilà
mais ouais trop matérialiste et c'était
un peu les mêmes problèmes que les ordis
y avait alors à leurs débuts en fait
voilà quoi si on a une tour plus on peut
facilement rendre une pièce et ça va on
est toujours bien mais il fait pousser
quatre longues et clément avec continue
dans l'esprit à fond fait des singles
vous y prendre pions assez logique
quelque part parce que ça va permettre
aux fausses évite de jouer donc fou
prend des cinq et il a fait fou des six
développe en développant la dernière
pièce donc qui permet de visages 2 qui
permet mentalement à tour de rentrer en
jeu et donc jeté pièce noire joue le
lieu de fodé sylla raté un truc hyper
joly qui était f projet de man en bas ça
ne rentre pas de qui qui vaut le coup
d'oeil
roy prend cavaliers 3 donc baden le
cavalier fait une fourchette mais fo
prend mais l'idée en fait aidé à enlever
le cavalier et permettre aux juifs ou
d'entrer en piste et de fer france 3 et
sur roy g1
il y avait tous ces cinq tout simplement
entre guillemets qui gagnait et c'est
assez surprenant parce que on se rend
pas compte que les noirs et spécialement
de grosses menaces
enfin on comprend que si on fait une
découverte et comprendre fouilles amat
mais simplement les découvertes fatale
c'est censé être cavaliers de 200
cavaliers f3 mais les deux cas sont
contrôlés par la dame qui pourrait
prendre et défendre son [ __ ] donc à
première vue il n'y a pas de gros danger
nous ont dit oui bon maintien je te fais
ces trois bâtons jetés change le fou et
là c'est là le coup de folie damev 4
fantastiques
l'idée ce que si fou prend dame bon ma
découverte qui arrive trois matchs ou
même cavalier 2 c'est pareil voilà parce
qu'il ya double échec et laurent n'a pas
de quête mesdames f4 même si les blancs
séparant dames 1
à ce moment là ont fait la découverte en
dame prend d'un me prend dans me prend
fou prend matin voilà très joli tableau
de ma de finale
le roi est attrapé par les fous donc le
foulard est celui-là est enfermé par ses
propres pièces ici voilà vont s'arrêter
fantastique mais c'est très dur à voir
enfin même maintenant je veux dire c'est
une vente longue et faut il penser
qu'après phocéen qui est juste pas de
défense
ça paraît assez improbable et n'a pas
été jouer mais donc à l'époque juste je
dois dire il avait une liste est déjà
hyper bon dans le calcul et le jeu
d'attaqué c'était plus donc le jeu
positionnelle banias sur les ouvertures
qui était pas comme maintenant mais déjà
de deux très beaux joueurs quoique est
très dangereux alors food & cie sa a été
joué et avec les blancs ifeda main pour
éventuellement échanger les dames et
s'avère que ça se veut être la faute
décisives et il va trouver une
combinaison une très jolie combinaison
finale ici avec les leurs étaient
vitales en fait de jeu un coup comme peu
l'idée en fait c'est surtout prend au
monde fou prenait 3 et se fout participe
à la défense il est pas à bloquer la
barre des 5
coupé du jeu et bomba les blancs ont
quand même toujours une tour de plus et
des pièces noir vers le roi mais ça se
tient coi en fait comme position alors
il a fait d'amener un bond qui quand
même sur le papier a l'air assez logique
en se disant oui je me débarrasser de
tad à mach 4
et puis on va voir et là donc la
combinaison si vous la cherchez il ya
allez bien quoi c'est un maître fort
c'est quand même très pas évident vous
pouvez mettre en pause pour les autres
on continue donc il après angers 2
reprend et boom doom 3 3 sacrifice de
dames bon on apprend au quai à ses
obligés si jamais le blanc le roi blanc
recul en juin il y avait quelques livres
3 matchs donc pas trop le choix
découverte donc je faisais 8 qui
attaquent le rhin et le roi a pas trop
de cases dire que la halle okaïdi s'en
occupe
là le fou des 600 occupe et la bombe a
évidemment il peut donc y continue son
avancée cavalière trois échecs il
continue sa route et pouget quatre
matchs donc pas très beau sacrifice de
dames et donc on voit dans cette partie
toute l'habileté tactique de qu'ils
iraient de ski voilà mes parties typique
de l'époque en fait tous où c'était la
guerre totale sur l'échiquier il n'y
avait pas vraiment de conception très
stratégique
c'était juste on vise le roi fond on
donne tout et on agresse et c'était les
échecs romantique à l'époque donc se
donner de belles parties donc évidemment
dont les repasse avec l'ordi on va
toujours trouver des erreurs mais pour
les tableaux de match pour le jeu
d'attaqué c'est quand même intéressant
pour l'activité des pièces voilà il
n'avait pas peur d'envoyer des pions des
tours qui servent à rien de l'autre côté
de l'échiquier en se concentrant à fond
là où il y avait le roi mais c'est
surtout donc le jeu de défense qui a
bien progressé et on s'est rendu compte
qu'on était obligés de prendre tout ce
qu'on nous donnait et qu'on pouvait
prendre un peu et prendre pour la survie
du roi voilà séance a surtout que le jeu
de défense à a bien progressé depuis
donc voilà
maintenant on va s'attaquer à pikine un
joueur qu'on regardera et donc on fera
pas mal de vidéos sur lui évidemment
allé à bonne journée à tous et à très
bientôt quoi